Hey guys, I wanted to make a video that's a little out of the norm from what I usually do.
Uh, this is in relation to the Stoneman Douglas shootings and first and foremost
I have to say that I'm incredibly proud of the way the kids have been handling themselves, how they've been
demonstrating all across the country in the organization of marches and talks with
people in political spheres. And usually, I stay out of anything that has to do with politics or religion or anything of the above.
But in this particular case, I felt I needed to say something because
some of my fans have been affected by this and some of my fans are out there
demonstrating about this. And I wanted to say something because I don't feel it's right that kids
have to be the ones on the frontlines of this fight.
And - and I wanted to throw in my support and give my thoughts on the matter for whatever that may be worth.
But to give you a background, um,
I have an extensive background and experience with guns.
My father was a
24-year Army man. He was a member of the NRA.
He taught me about guns from a very early age, and he taught me to respect them
and how to properly handle guns. I have gone to the shooting range many times. I've shot all kinds of guns.
My dad even built muzzle loader rifles as a hobby.
So, when I say these things, just know that it's not coming from a place of ignorance.
And first and foremost, I want to say that I don't think people should be able to access assault rifles.
There's no beating around the bush. There's no kidding about it. There's no exaggerations.
Assault rifles exist solely to kill people. And you could say the same thing about all guns,
but assault rifles are especially - they don't have any purpose in hunting. They have a purpose in
self-defense, only to the point where they can kill
multiple people with a lot of bullets in a very large magazine.
And...
I know I'm going out on a limb into saying this outright
but, I'm a hundred percent in the field that we need to ban assault rifles.
And I know that people will say that gun control laws are not the thing that can change this,
or at least they'll say that it's not the only thing that can change this. But in my mind
why not do everything in our power to try to protect our kids?
Or our people, or our fellow countrymen or our neighbors. And in the avenue of trying to attack this from both sides,
why don't we stop
stigmatizing mental health? Why don't we stop treating it like some sort of problem that people just need to bear alone?
That should be the first and foremost if everything not just in these, but in general because there's so many people out there
suffering silently with mental illnesses that need help and are so afraid to go out and get it,
because of the way we treat it in this country. And also why do we require more licensing and registration
for cars than we do for guns?
I know that people abide very closely by the Second Amendment, and me as a proud American,
I'm very proud of our Constitution.
But at the same time there has to be some measure of control.
I know that people want to be able to bear arms
and I respect that. I come from a family that was all about that.
But that doesn't mean that we can't have some measure of control over these
extremely dangerous tools. In the end people will say that I'm spouting ignorance or that I don't know what I'm talking about.
Or that I'm saying things that are wrong, and that is fine.
But right now, the only thing that I can think of is why shouldn't we be doing absolutely
everything in our power to help?
Now is not the time for talk.
Now is not the time for empty promises. Now is the time to do something for
the people that are suffering most from this.
And I want to end this by saying that these kids that are out demonstrating, they are an inspiration.
An absolute inspiration, not just to me but to everybody watching across the country.
And if you're watching this and you are out there demonstrating or you're organizing marches.
Or you're talking to the people who are supposedly in power of these decisions,
keep it up.
Cause the world is listening, the country is listening.
People will try to ignore you and people will try to dismiss your opinion, but you are the future of this country
and you are the future of the world, and your actions dictate what our future will be.
So, don't give up the fight, stay strong
and
thanks for watching.
Bye.